THE PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICIALS AND
FOLLOW THESE GUIDELINES TO
DECREASE THE AMOUNT OF VIRUS.
>> Tucker: >> Tucker: I
APPRECIATE THAT THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME.
>> THANKS TUCKER.
THE CHAIRMAN OF THE SENATE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE SOLD MORE
THAN $1 MILLION IN STOCK IN
FEBRUARY AFTER LEARNING HOW
DEVASTATING THE CHINESE
CORONAVIRUS COULD BE.
HE HAD INSIDE INFORMATION ABOUT
WHAT COULD HAPPEN TO THE COUNTRY
WHICH IS NOW HAPPENING, BUT HE
DIDN’T WANT THE PUBLIC.
HE DIDN’T GIVE A PROPER TIME OF
ADDRESS OR GO TO THE TELEVISION
TO SOUND THE ALARM.
HE DIDN’T BED, JUST TEN DAYS
BEFORE CLAIMING AMERICA WAS
"BETTER PREPARED FOR THE
CORONAVIRUS.
HE DIDN’T DO THOSE THINGS BUT
INSTEAD WHAT DID HE DO?
HE DUMPED HIS SHARES INTO HOTEL
STOCKS SO WE WOULDN’T LOSE
MONEY.
THEN HE STAYED SILENT.
MAYBE THERE IS AN HONEST
EXPLANATION FOR WHAT HE DID.
IF THERE IS, HE SHOULD SHARE IT
WITH THE REST OF US IMMEDIATELY.
OTHERWISE, HE MUST RESIGN FROM
THE SENATE AND FACE PROSECUTION
FOR INSIDER TRADING.
THERE IS NO GREATER MORAL CRIME
AND BETRAYING YOUR COUNTRY IN A